hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to night lights the night
blight as the Sun does go down and up
comes the moon the terror from the
darkness will be arriving soon they will
hide in the shadows and strike sudden
and quick but sometimes more mischievous
in you they shall trick here is the goal
and Trust this rule of thumb you must
survive until morning when the daylight
does come so be warned and made fill you
with fright there is nothing more scary
than a hungry night blight ok so this
game is interesting because you take the
perspective of a child and you're trying
to Oh Monday safe in your bed or so it
may seem they come from below whilst you
slumber and dream as they close in they
will growl and make noise let's feed
them quickly with one of your toys
whenever the shadow of night falls on to
the globe you can be grabbed from any
wardrobe best keep your eyes peeled in
the doors firmly shut else they will
leap out in their sharp teeth sharp cut
okay so it's night based basically kind
of like five nights at Freddy's was how
to play those buttons those buttons
those things do all that don't die oh
there's a night blight under your
parents and your sister's bed well
that's not good what do I do about that
uh hi remember to feed them toys when
they growl I'll try my best
holy crap like I loved I mean obviously
any game from the perspective of a child
is reminiscent of among the sleep and do
a lesser-known degree baby blues I think
it was called I'm not sure also keep the
Wardrobe shudder you'll die there are
four total four in total plus the fridge
man how am I supposed to be able to do
this there's a lot of responsibility for
just a child
protect your family till 7:00 a.m. good
luck oh I playing now okay well holy
crap
action drop okay running equals tired
equals danger okay
good thing I dropped that battle plan
before this happened and good thing I
didn't tell any of my family I mean I'm
still young enough to need a baby crib
oh okay
whoa oh I see
can I get that heap okay so I have to
feed them toys houki oh-oh-oh-oh
was this the sound of one of the
wardrobes opening oh boy oh boy oh no
maybe
oh I have no idea what I'm getting
myself into
hi how's it going what are you doing
what are you up to
Wow how you do okay no no no no no no no
need to stay son who's growling who
needs a toy okay
holy hell feed the toy educate the thing
get the thing okay all right so it's not
a click-and-drag it's it's a click and
you hold it okay oh you know like you
this I don't know where they are what
was that
no thank you who's there
oh I got a toy I think I got a toy I
don't know how to toy hand there we go I
got a toy so anybody want a toy oh hey
what's go on you want a toy here's a toy
okay you're welcome I think that was a
thank you and I'm not entirely sure how
am I supposed to do this oh boy
I don't even know what time it is I'm
assuming the giant ticking sounds of
clocks that I can actually see okay you
need to know the toy you're a little bit
greedy probably my parents bed needs to
talk
sorry sorry I'll be right back once I
deliver this Furby into the jaws of hell
no no don't kill me I love you shut up
Furby there's sacrifices for the good of
all my family whoa
upstairs damn it this fridge No okay all
right I'm on the way I'm on the way I
got the food delivery it's midnight
toddler buffet shut up you a-hole got it
got it okay got that all right Oh
goddamn all right then I did not know
that was where it was I was heading
right towards it I was pretty sure that
I saw something there at the last minute
and let that get open a little too much
it's my first time go easy on me got an
assembly of toys there no big deal a big
deal and this school yeah I can bring
the stool around this stool means I can
go get more toys that are higher up cuz
I'm just a wee late Oh baby I would
never be able to get the toy dinner too
high up except for right now yup
oh no this priceless dragon set you I
can't feed that to the monsters shut up
I'm coming for you you're slightly ajar
no I said no I said no no I said no I
said no after you
okay I wonder why they aren't under my
bed why are they under all my family's
bed why do I have to be here that this
family deserves oh you know I'm I've got
a sad childhood all my toys keep getting
eaten by monsters
I gotcha order up just gonna make a
quick check in my room to close the
closet in there so that they can't kill
me cuz if I don't do it and then I go
back to bed and then I'm all eaten I'll
be dead and that's the end of that Marky
move crept the hallways with utter
fright who knew if he would survive the
night
all these little night flights are full
of fright mark EMU in his plight oh the
eyes of the toys burn bright
yum yum shut up thunk thunk that's the
sound of things new fridge is almost
open whoo
okay don't blink don't move don't blink
don't blink I think that this game could
definitely benefit from a little bit of
music like the small subtle like
childlike chimes you know from the music
box that would be really like really
good to add a little bit of atmosphere
to this because there's not a whole lot
going on besides the tick tocking of the
clock is there an actual baby in there
oh that's a little weird
whoa hi Sandberg oh Heisenberg what oh
okay
Breaking Bad references feed you feed
you I got it on it yum yum yum I know
why is hot why is Heisenberg here why
are we worried about Heisenberg I seem
to be running a lot but doesn't seem to
be getting me in too much trouble okay
it's almost time come on it's almost
time baby okay so there we go night
flights are deadly and only children can
see also the taste of small babies fills
them with glee as they grow near the
baby will cry it's been the mobile
swiftly us baby shall duck the garage
door may be opened and breathing you'll
hear if this is the case this means a
knight blade is near so press the red
button to keep the door shut tight this
will kill keep you safe throughout the
long night okay so that was night blight
this is a really interesting game I mean
obviously it was made by one guy and the
first night was a little slow just
because it was introduction but even I
managed to die because I'm an idiot and
I wasn't paying attention but I imagine
that each night further will add a
little bit more complexity to the game
so if you want to see the rest of the
game let me know down in the comments
below I might do a full playthrough of
it but I really want to know what you
guys think of it
also be sure to check the link in the
description if you want to play it for
yourself thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]